surveillance video released by police
shows protesters running toward officers
in what police called a coordinated
attack Atlanta's police chief said the
demonstrators hurled Molotov cocktails
rocks and fireworks to disrupt the
construction of a police training center
this was a very violent attack that
occurred this evening very violent
attack this wasn't about a Public Safety
Training Center this was about Anarchy
and this was about the attempt to
destabilize protesters say the target
was an empty construction trailer that
was set Ablaze no police officers were
injured
a nearby Music Festival also held to
oppose the construction but separately
organized was interrupted when officers
descended
to draw guns on unarmed protesters they
decided to
um to tackle and tase people in in the
view of children the protests have been
happening since the project was
announced in 2021 the city of Atlanta
says the 90 million dollar facility
within Forest land will provide training
space for police and firefighters
protesters say it's an effort to further
militarize law enforcement after the
police killings of George Floyd and
other black Americans and they say it's
an attack on the wilani forest of the
Native Muskogee Creek people this is a
movement that's trying to save a force
and a woman just trying to stop a
militarized police training center from
being built which will cause more harm
to working class and for black
communities in particular located here
in Atlanta
a January confrontation between police
and protesters led to the death of a 26
year old environmental activist police
say he opened fire on them first they
will frame the um Forest protectors as
domestic terrorists while they use
weapons of of Terror on
um Atlanta residents more protests are
planned as police have vowed to see
through construction of the training
center to the end
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington